[Music]
foreign
will save you follows a young girl named
Brynn who has a darker past she is sort
of deeply hated by the town that she
lives in
[Music]
she is secluded and she keeps to herself
she built this bubble that she feels
safe in a few minutes into the movie
that bubble gets popped
it's absolutely terrifying
[Applause]
[Music]
friends of an alien in her community
and then this other alien story happens
on top of that
there's so many things I loved about
playing this character she has a major
conflict the emotions that she's going
through they were real to me
Brynn runs a lot in this movie Brian
said I want you to run like Tom Cruise
and I thought I was a runner before this
film
I am now we throw a couple of curve
balls it's a lot of fun
foreign
[Music]